Tan Jing Jing is looking for her child
she believes that her son mu chan was
sold to human traffickers she is not
receiving any help from the Chinese
authorities on the contrary she thinks
there's been a cover-up I've been
looking for him for three years give him
back time and again children in China
disappear without a trace the chances of
finding them are slim
Tanjung jing lives near beijing with her
younger son uhm she divorced three years
ago
yay chen was born after the divorce his
older brother Lu Chen stayed with his
father taunting Jing was later awarded
custody but when she went to pick him up
mu Cheng wasn't there my ex-husband
threatened me he said if you report me
I'll kidnap the boy then you'll never
see him again since then my only purpose
in life is to protect my younger son and
find my older one I'm terrified everyday
Tanjung Jing is convinced her ex-husband
sold the child tens of thousands of
children disappear in China every year
there are no official figures she
petitioned the court and filed charges
with the police she goes through her
paperwork again and again all her
applications were rejected I'm
especially afraid for him when winter
comes I think maybe he's out there
somewhere
I imagine that he's living with people
who treat him badly that he suffers
unbearably and I'm helpless
there's nothing I can do for you either
finally she has a small glimmer of hope
an officer told her the address where
the child should be now Thanh Jing Jing
is on her way
can you don't you of course I'm excited
I'm very nervous but I'm so glad there's
progress I know he's alive and I can
possibly find him what are the that
gives me hope and makes me happy
tan Jing Jing has a long journey ahead
of her and she has to be careful the
state is targeting troublesome people
like her even if she can't prove it she
believes that corrupt officials are
involved in the disappearance of her son
she stops halfway on her trip to leave
hñ with her sister in order to keep him
safe
the journey continues by car identity
papers are checked and recorded on buses
and trains and Tanjung Jing fears that
shall be intercepted by security
authorities before she reaches her
destination
I made myself up to look older I hope
they won't recognize me she also got a
new haircut to change her appearance
finally she reaches the village she
knows the address but most of the house
numbers are missing she doesn't dare ask
directions because she's afraid her son
will be moved again this village is
really big I don't know where to start
looking tall yeah the village
kindergarten
Tanjung gin carefully questions a carer
of the village children none of the kids
here look like my son do you know where
number 123 is no well then I'll keep
going
the next morning she wants to try the
local police
maybe the authorities here are more
helpful among all the children who
disappear in China every year those with
the worst fate end up as slaves or being
forced to beg and that's what Tanjung
Jing is most afraid of only a fraction
of the children are discovered the
officers take time to listen to her case
and promise to look for the child that
very day I'm so happy
boom hang that in it I feel like I'm
finally getting justice I'll soon see my
son again I'm so grateful
Tanjung Jing left our village at sixteen
and has been working as a waitress ever
since but since the search for her son
she can hardly take on regular work her
dream is to open her own restaurant just
as soon as she has her son back
the next day the police called Thanh
jinjing back in she hopes that means
she'll be able to see her son again I
don't know how he'll react he hasn't
seen me in three years he may not
remember me I'm a little scared and I'm
very nervous you never know
after a short while she returns without
her son the officers only took blood for
a genetic test they told me that I
didn't follow the right procedures
I've tried everything gone everywhere
now they say it was all wrong what's the
right way to do this I tried a lawyer
without success I'm at a loss I'm just a
country girl all I know is that I want
to find my child
a few months later the authorities
finally confirmed that Tanjung dings son
does live where she had been looking for
him
but she isn't allowed to see him he is
now officially adopted I don't know if I
can find him just that my son lives in
that village I need to get back there
and find him it's the only thing I can
do now
Tanjung king now knows that mu chen
lives with her family that had no sons
in the countryside it's important for
parents to have a son to look after them
in their old age the result is a
thriving black market for trafficking in
boys
evie only that ever since we left town
we've been followed there's someone
after us all the time does anyone know
this child you there you know him I can
see it you've seen him haven't you how
old is he
five never seen him before where is he
supposed to be
Tanjung Jing doesn't get anywhere with
her charm she grows more desperate I've
been trying to find him for three years
this is my child he was sold to someone
in your village three years I want my
child back
what about the mayor
mayor come out a child was sold to your
village it's been recorded here in the
family register he goes to kindergarten
here how could that be who paid for it
where did this family get the money to
bribe everyone damn you all criminals no
one will save you you misfits you crooks
it is another setback in the fight for
her child and against a corrupt system
but tan Jing Jing will not give up until
she has her son back